une nouvelle confrontation procès
villemin elle a opposé muriel bolle la
belle-soeur de bernard laroche aux
gendarmes et les magistrats ont eu droit
une nouvelle fois de versions
contradictoires dominique verdeilhan
gilles dobler une fois de plus la cour
d'assises de dijon est invité à un
voyage en arrière destination la
gendarmerie de bruit hier dans les
vosges le 2 novembre 84 muriel bolle qui
a donné sa seconde version celle qui
accuse bernard laroche
une version qui dit elle depuis lui a
été soufflée par les enquêteurs le
président henri scène not dubitatif que
pour une déclaration faite sous la
dictée il y a beaucoup les détails que
les gendarmes ne pouvaient pas inventé
ou bien vous avez dit vrai ou bien les
gendarmes sont des faussaires de la pire
espèce lance-t-il agacé aux témoins en
revanche muriel reconnaît une chose elle
a bien dit que les gendarmes étaient ses
copains c'est parce que j'avais peur
d'eux c'était pour me protéger
le commandant cesma n'a pas le même
souvenir de cette garde à vue
je lui ai demandé si elle avait bien
conscience de ce qu'elle disait j'avais
en face de moi quel cas de détendu qui
n'avait pas l'air traumatisé par son
audition elle était soulagé comme libéré
et puis à son tour le commandant cesma
affiche son intime conviction je reste
persuadé que muriel bolle est rentré
ignorante dans cette affaire embarquez à
son corps défendant
d'ailleurs bernard laroche ne pouvait
pas savoir que grégory serait tout seul
il a agi dans un état second preuve la
lettre de revendication a été écrite à
la va vite c'est la folie y passe une
folie travaillé par la haine drôle de
procès où les retours en arrière donnent
le vertige ya huit jours des témoins des
experts faisait porter les soupçons sur
christine villemin